the thing that compelled me to do this
movie was the central idea and we've all
seen robot movies before but this is
different
these aren't sentient robots these
aren't autonomous thinking machines
these are basically puppets or tools we
stay at home and were controlling these
things by Kary asleep from afar and
really it's like a metaphor for the
internet for how we're living our lives
right now in this digital age it's it's
the question it's a moral question but
it certainly poses the question are we
abstracting our social relationships in
such a way that we're losing sanity
exchange two people have died while
connected to their surrogates I think we
may actually have a homicide here first
one in 15 years we are plugged in it
seems during almost all of our conscious
waking time and it really leads the
question of like well you know are we
using this machinery in service to our
goals or are we actually kind of
enslaved to this machinery there's the
potential for anything to happen because
you can choose in reality through this
robot we really tried to build it
organically from the idea itself and
what's so wonderful about this graphic
novel is that had the idea in it it was
so simple and yet had never been done
the way we get to know agent Peters is
really as a plastic robot for the most
part into family we sort of note her in
that in that body there's a few moments
where we meet her as the real person
which is quite jarring because they're
not they're not what you would expect
and and I think you know
it's in the movie they're great when you
see the operators behind the robots it's
in the same way is it's much more easy
to send you a text or an email than to
pick up the phone and call you let alone
like get my car and drive over to see
you these are all things that are
convenient for us but again they're just
beginning to minimize the sort of the
human experience making any connection
that we feel to each other so it just
leads to the question of how is it that
we're all more plugged into each other
and connected than ever before but an
assembly work more disconnected than
we've ever been
now that's what the leads